مع كل الأسئلة حول لقاح jj
وكيف يتراكم ضد
لقاحات covid الأخرى ،
فإن خلاصة القول هي أن جميع
اللقاحات الثلاثة المعتمدة في السوق
الآن في الولايات المتحدة
يجب أن تمنع الفيروس من قتل
لقاح فايزر الذي يتطلب طلقتين
هو 95 فعال ضد الفيروس
الحديث
الذي يتطلب أيضًا لقطعتين
، لقاح فعال بنسبة 94 في المائة ، لقاح واحد فقط كان
فعالًا بنسبة 66 في تجربة عالمية ، لكنه
أثبت فعاليته بنسبة 85 في المائة
ضد المرض الشديد ومثلهما
الآخران
فعالان بنسبة 100 في المائة ضد الموت
مما يعني أنه
لا أحد  من حصل على هذه اللقاحات مات من
كوفيد ،
لماذا لم يتم اعتماد أسترازينيكا للاستخدام
في الولايات المتحدة ،
أفهم أن إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير طلبت من
أسترازينيكا
إجراء تجارب المرحلة الثالثة الإضافية ، دكتور
بيتر هوتس الذي يدرس اللقاحات ،
يقول إن هناك بعض الالتباس حول
نتائج أسترازينيكا
بما في ذلك واحدة جزئية  أظهرت الدراسة أن
جرعة أولى أصغر من
لقاح أسترازينيكا بجرعتين تصطدم
بالفعالية من  62 في المائة إلى
90 في
المائة 62 باستخدام الجرعات القياسية و
بجرعة منخفضة متبوعة بجرعة قياسية
بحيث كان هذا أحد
المخاوف من
أن الرقم 90 كان عددًا منخفضًا
من الأشخاص المسجلين
أعتقد أنهم يريدون نتيجة
المرحلة  ثلاث تجارب أجريت في الولايات
المتحدة وإذا كنت تتساءل عن كيفية تكديس كل من
هذه اللقاحات ضد
المتغيرات المختلفة التي تنتشر الآن ،
يقول الدكتور هوتز إن هذه اللقاحات الأربعة تعمل
بشكل جيد حقًا ضد السلالة
الأصلية والمتغير البريطاني ، البديل الجنوب أفريقي
أكثر صعوبة
يقول إنه يعتقد أن Moderna ستحمي جزئيًا
من هذه السلالة
وأن شركة Pfizer تعمل بشكل جيد ضدها على
الرغم من أنها تنتج عددًا أقل من
الأجسام المضادة المعادلة للفيروس ،
لذلك لا يزال مستوى الحماية غير
واضح
ولقاح جونسون وجونسون الذي تم
اختباره بالفعل في جنوب إفريقيا وهناك
انخفاض
في مستوى فعاليته الوقائية ولكن
لا يزال هناك بعض
ما كان حول جرعة واحدة حول 57
مناعة وقائية لذا قللت
في الحماية الجزئية astrazeneca
يقول إنه كان فعالًا بنسبة 10 بالمائة فقط
ضد البديل الجنوب أفريقي ،
والخبر السار هو أن
لقاحات جونسون
وجونسون أسترازينكا وفايزر
لا تحميك فحسب ، بل يبدو أنها تساعد أيضًا في
وقف انتشار الفيروس ،
لذا فإن الثلاثة منهم  نعم وليس
ماديرا ،
أعتقد أن الحداثة على الأرجح تفعل ذلك أيضًا ، فأنا
فقط لم نظهر ذلك بعد ، تُظهر
البيانات من إسرائيل أن جرعتين من
لقاح فايزر
فعالان بنسبة 92 في المائة في منع
العدوى
بما في ذلك الأشخاص الذين لا تظهر عليهم
الأعراض
المحتملة إذا حصلنا عليها  تم تطعيم عدد كافٍ من الأشخاص ،
يمكننا إيقاف انتقال الفيروس ،
وأعتقد أنه يمكننا تحصين طريقنا للخروج من
هذا الوباء ،
ما نصيحتك للناس عندما
يتعلق الأمر بالتطعيم ،
فلن يكون لديك الكثير من الخيارات فيما يتعلق
بما تحصل عليه  هل يمكن لكل هذه
اللقاحات أن تنقذ حياتك
راندي ك سي إن إن ويست بالم بيتش فلوريدا